cbs news senior national security
contributor and former acting cia
director that's michael morell
is with us now from washington he was by
the way cia deputy director when osama
bin laden was killed
in a u.s raid in pakistan michael thank
you so much for joining us you know
yesterday the president seemed to imply
that this death was much bigger than the
death of osama bin laden
i think most people weren't even aware
there was a competition but can you put
this in perspective for us what this
really means
yeah so there wasn't a competition um
both
both operations were very significant
significant setbacks for al qaeda
in bin laden's case and isis and
baghdadi's case
so baghdadi was still the operational
leader
of isis he was guiding the resurgence of
isis so even though they lost their
caliphate
earlier this year they were in the
process of resurging
10 to 30 000 operatives on the
syria-iraq border
he was helping to orchestrate that and
he was also the group's inspirational
leader
as holly mentioned so without him they
lose both of that
history has shown us gail that when you
take a terrorist leader off the
battlefield
it takes a while for the replacement to
find their way to learn the job so
that's a setback
and most important it sends a message to
all the leadership that they're at risk
and they start worrying more about their
own security than they do about running
their group
and thinking about operations so it is a
setback definitely
isis will not go away just because of
this but it is a setback
michael what's the significance of where
baghdadi was found
so if so anthony i'm not sure there's
much significance
um you know a lot's been made that this
is al qaeda territory
but after the caliphate um collapsed a
number of isis fighters made their way
from
on the part of syria and iraq where they
were to
this part of northwestern syria um which
is sort of a no man's land so
um i'm not sure it it's it's of
significance
in any way beyond the best place to hide
michael president trump says that u.s
forces on the ground took quote highly
sensitive material and information end
quote in the raid what would you be
looking for in that material
absolutely good question i think four
things one is
any current plots or operations that's
the first thing you look for
um the second would be how is the
organization
actually working today how is it
communicating with each other
how is money moving um you know how is
it operating on a day-to-day basis
third the leadership who's in charge in
what position
how do they interact with each other
who's important who's not and then
lastly
big strategic plans and intentions those
are the four things you're going to be
looking for
all right michael morell thank you very
much michael